let's go back to the phones let's talk
to sue in seattle
sue how are you this morning doing well
congrats on your new show thank you so
much thanks for joining us
here at the very beginning you are in on
something big right is that what you say
when you're trying to get somebody to
invest like an avon
or something like you're an early
adopter sue this is this is going to be
huge for you
so how can i help what's going on well i
wanted to talk to you because you've
worked in higher ed
i have been invested in my job
for now 13 years because of the dream
of free college education for my
daughter
dropped her off and i thought i was
going to feel you know really relieved
and be
really excited but i got home and
all i could think of is okay 45 months
to go
to sit through this job that i've
learned that i'm kind of
really sick of i've been in you know now
that i've been on this debt-free journey
i'm
two years away from being debt-free i've
been really dreaming about what can i do
next i've been
thinking about what my other
possibilities could be
and now i'm feeling a little like
god i'm really kind of stuck in this
thing because
her tuition is tied to doing this job i
can't quit
i can't move on to a better thing and
even when i do get out of
out of debt i'm still going to have to
continue to do a job
i i really don't love anymore so what do
you do for
um your your school
give me a call i work in the career
center and i work with
students and employers so that is a
thinkless
challenging job for those of you who
don't know
career centers and admissions folks
and development folks folks who raise
money those are the three positions on a
college campus
that no matter what is going on in the
world they are judged by a single number
at the end of a calendar year you either
succeeded or you failed
if you're an english professor you are
helping folks learn to write
learn to read learn to think broadly
learn to think deeply
and but there's no centralized metric
that you can post up that you have to
put up for the world to see whether you
succeeded or failed right
i was a student affairs guy so i was
always dealing with after hours things
hard things
um and the the how i judged my job or
how people
judged my job was uh it's amorphous
right it's
are we helping students learn these out
of the classroom experiences and things
a career services person
is how many of our students got jobs you
failed right
what a tough tough job i've known some
extraordinary
career services folks and they are
always under the gun there
so what part about your job you love
oh god i or maybe none of it man it
won't hurt my feelings maybe none of it
maybe you're just sick of the whole
thing
there i have bright spots i actually of
sending out an email message
to students about an opportunity and
seeing somebody take action on it
like when somebody actually went through
to the next step and applied to that
opportunity and then gets the job i
love that part um and i love being
yeah from behind the scenes i have new
software i can actually tell that that
happened
that is a thrill i love that piece um
and i'm actually kind of thinking
i like the the direct marketing of
those opportunities being able to do the
a b testing of
uh the messaging um and seeing which
kind of messages they actually respond
to
and um i'm loving that i'm getting to do
it career
virtually and doing it jointly with
other schools i'm actually kind of
excited about that possibility
what part of your job do you hate you
just just
every second you're like man i think i'm
gonna set myself on fire
just just to feel the heat like what's
what's that part of your job
oh there are
folks that i i know i've rage about
i mean like raged i had to storm out of
the office and stop
around a building before i could go back
and actually talk to people
that was about just dealing with
regulations and
getting approval to do things that just
make common sense but
i have to go through this process to
make something happen
common sense does not always drive
decision making in higher education
right
so now here's the here's the back out
here's the 30 000 foot view and i'll
simplify it for you and i'm going to put
you on the spot
is that cool yeah all right so
i want to think about this on a couple
of hundred year scale
and then a very like right this second
scale okay
if we were to back out a couple of
hundred years and think about
the and what i'm gonna do is not fair by
the way and i know that so just bear
with me here
um if we backed out a couple of hundred
years
and looked at the general sacrifices
people have been willing to make over
the years for their kid
for what comes next and then i
fast forward to the absolute
ridiculous challenge you have of a
single score metric job
that is that is dependent on there's
very few things you can control
right the economies in the tank students
can't even come in and meet with you
this a a new generation of student who
just thinks you've got a magic drawer
full of jobs right like hey i'm
graduating where's my job
and who doesn't always pay attention in
class and doesn't know how to do resumes
just
basic things um and you're judged on did
you get them a job or not right so
that's tough
but it's in the air conditioning you're
good at it you're
you can grind it out like you said for
four years and then your daughter can
write off into the sunset or your son
came out from the sunset that's one side
of it
the other side of it is playing a
10-year 20-year game the other way and
the reason i
when i think about that way i think does
your kid have to go to this school
is there another school that is free in
your community
that can do community college is there a
state
option in the area where your son or
daughter can
y'all can sit down and work out the
finances of and say
i can't do this job anymore or i've got
a great opportunity i'm transitioning
but this is going to cost us tuition and
that's a hard conversation for you to
have of course
but it's also a remarkable moment for
your
kid to see their mom thinking about
themselves
planning and the natural consequences of
stuff right so
i don't think any of those options are
bad but it's kind of an either or
right that you're going to grind it out
you're going to work really hard
and you're going to say i'm going to
make one of those little chains and i'm
going to spend the next four years doing
this job but also
building what's going to come next like
you would tell a you know a sophomore
who comes in to see you
or yeah get an exit strategy sooner
rather than later
and get out and let your son or daughter
know hey this is this is some
this is time for me to make my move and
this is gonna mean you're probably not
to change schools
yeah we we had the hardest conversations
already and she had already had to make
compromise on school she ended up at
okay my school was part of tuition
exchange so she got to go
out of my school basically but uh what
she wanted to study
is not available nearby where we're at
unfortunately
okay um but i'm committed to grinding it
out i just need some strategies to be
able to
survive it without you know wanting to
kill my colleagues and just
be a better person in general um
because i'm committed i'm going to have
to do the next four years and i'm going
to have to be
sanguine about it so i would recommend
this
inside of a school ecosystem and you
know this
if you love working with students if you
love the marketing part
if you love the collaborative part if
you like working
and reaching out in other universities
and having partnerships which schools
all across the country are having to do
right
now because it is just a sideways
hurricane
duty storm right now out there in higher
education there's students everywhere
they're not showing up in some schools
some schools are canceled some schools
are online all that
so schools are having to partner
together like never before
i want to recommend that you start
scouring
your own institution for places where
you can transition inside your
institution
i want you to scour your local area
where you wouldn't have to move
where you can find opportunities that
are going to be able to jump
institutions in different positions that
will get you that will still have the
tuition exchange but we'll have several
years
i'm not a huge fan of people just
resigning themselves to the next four
years going to be awful
or the next four years i'm going to have
to just suffer
even when it's for a greater good
sometimes we got to do that and that's
life
but if there's other options i really
want you to explore that
and then i want to tell you this story
that happened today and
maybe it will speak into the next four
years and this is a
a conversation not with your colleagues
not with your bosses not with
your child this is a conversation you
can have with the mirror
so i live about 30 minutes from work i
live out in the woods
um literally in the woods and i drove
into work today
and i'm notoriously behind i love
talking with people
i like just staring off into space i
like writing i was up at before
4am this morning trying to finish a a
book here that that we're trying to get
out
i was writing i was in the middle of it
and then i got to work
on time not on time i got on to work
before
on time which if you know me super rare
i agree
i walk in i sit down i get all my stuff
out
i start to work again on
on this book and my wife calls and says
i hate to tell you this but our son went
out to the car this morning with my
with her keys and left them in the back
of my truck
and she had to get my daughter to school
she had to get herself to a writing
event this morning
which meant i had and i had an hour
until we went on
set this morning until we started
recording
that meant i had to race to my car my
truck jump in
drive 30 minutes the other way drop off
a set of keys
oh dude the whale guy is there and i had
to talk to that guy for a second
drop jump back in my truck drive back
here
and get here just in time for james and
kelly to say hey we're about to we're
about to go live and then we're rocking
and rolling
why'd i tell you that annoying story the
whole time
i had this well in my soul of
my stinking kid doesn't pay attention
he's just blue
through life he's like a balloon just
floating around
like bouncing off of things he's got the
greatest heart
he's brilliant he's comically smarter
than i am
but he just is like through life and i
was thinking
i'm gonna set up this and then i would
stop and say no dude it was an accident
and then i'd drive another couple of
miles and then i would think you know
what dude
i'm gonna get that kid i'm gonna tell
him and then i have to exhale and say
all i can control in this moment all i
can control is my thoughts
and my actions and what i have is i have
an hour drive ahead of me 30 minutes one
way 30 minutes the other
i'm gonna have to get back to work go
straight into the recording studio and
get on the air
and i can be all fired up and my heart
rate can be high
and i can go bananas or i can let this
go man
i am going to have a conversation with
my son tonight i'm not going to be mad
about it he didn't do it on purpose
we are going to talk about paying
attention and i get to choose my
response to that
and i realized in those moments as i was
driving
i've been practicing this for five years
since i spent some time with a man named
randy harris there in texas who's a monk
who taught me how to be mindful who
taught me how to start
this long journey of flexing the muscles
of controlling my thoughts and my
actions
and i got to decide how i respond to
this stuff
i get to respond whether i just smile
and say
i don't know what's going on in your
life man that's not about me and so sue
i'm telling you this to tell you this
i'm telling you this to tell you this
that's a little bit redundant
i tell you that long story to tell you
this it could be
that the next 12 months the next 24
months of a really hard job
a thinkless painful frustrating job
that has a higher purpose right now you
are helping folks navigate a messy job
situation and that's a gift to have a
good career services person
you are helping your kid go to school
for free with free tuition
that's a big deal you're setting them up
that's a legacy move on your part
but it could be a moment for you to get
with a counselor
to get with a group of women there in
your community
that say you know what we're gonna
practice for the next 12 months
controlling our thoughts and controlling
our actions we're going to learn how to
exhale when somebody gets in our
business
we're going to learn how to literally
heap coals of kindness
on frustrating annoying faculty members
on jerk employers who show up late or
don't even show up at all
students who are don't pay attention and
respond to emails
ridiculous administrators we're going to
turn that corner and in 14 months
and 30 months and 40 months i want you
to circle back and say
i worked on my heart i worked on my
responses i worked on my thoughts and my
actions
and now i'm a person who can bring calm
to chaos i'm a person who can bring
laughter
to hard situations i'm just a person of
joy
because i chose to and this could be one
of those moments
i make fun of crossfit a lot it's a
great workout program but just the
yeah dude this could be one of those
crossfits for your soul for the next 24
36 months and so sue i say go for it
and if you again if you have to call
your kid in a couple of months and quit
i fully understand i left the industry
it got big for my heart i got too much
for my soul in a season
and i was blessed with an awesome
opportunity to
transition out but i get the just can't
do it anymore i get it i get it i get it
so blessings to you sue when you decide
what you're going to do circle back and
give me a call i'd love to hear how it's
going
and thank you so much for the call